assalamualaikum greetings a peace how
you guys doing you probably heard about
the amazing news of Sinead O'Connor
accepting Islam stick with me as I make
this short quick video commenting and
giving a breakdown for the not getting
Muslims out there on what she actually
did to accept Islam what's she saying
let's watch it together
and I can go ahead and help familiarize
you with this step that she took a
little bit better how's that let's do it
that's Sinead O'Connor and what she was
saying right here she was saying some
like Al hamdulillah now this is kind of
the equivalent to hallelujah like all
praises to God pretty much this is what
it means and she said she said the
Shahada now let's go ahead and watch her
make this Shahada now go ahead and
comment more on and Hum did it not and
bring it more close to home towards the
end of the video on some some other
points really important that you can
connect with even appreciate it even
more as I say they should have that I
testify there is no god except allah and
i testify that Muhammad is the servant
and his messenger I announce that I have
embraced Islam right I have accepted
this film except as my religion with my
free will
I will continue to respect all other
religions including Christianity but my
way of life my religion is Islam
she has freely taken the choice instead
of worshiping money worshiping fame
worshiping saints human beings
messengers you name it anything in
creation she said no I'm not gonna do
that and that's the proclamation of
faith that's the testimony that she just
did then anybody who believes this and
this is something that it's so simple
and it just it goes with what is already
intrinsically built inside of all of us
now what does she say she said that she
bore witness the Shahada is bearing
witness again be giving birth there's
something inside of the human being
there's something innate intrinsically
built in all of us some called the God
spot where we're hot-wired to believe in
the Creator now you might have come up
and you might have been worshiping human
beings you might have been worshipping
some part of the creation you might have
been doing some very strange and
esoteric things that just didn't make
sense and you didn't find that peace and
solitude that that happiness in life and
maybe you were very scientific and
analytical and when you looked at what's
your parents or your ancestors were upon
it just didn't make sense so let's go to
what really made sense for her and also
it is something that Jesus did it was
something that if you were living during
the time of Jesus or Moses or Abraham or
any of the messengers it's a consistent
chain linking back to the beginning so
it's not a new religion it's a testimony
that you would have been uttering for
instance if you were during the time of
Jesus you would say ashhadu as she was
saying ash-hadu an LA ilaha illallah WA
ash hadu ana muhammadan abduhu wa
rasuluh look so she said there's nothing
worthy of worship first there's a
negation there's a negation of all
deities all objects of worship anything
that people worship today yesterday
anything in creation she's negating that
there there's nothing worthy there's no
deity or object
worthy of any worship not an ounce net a
pound no worship am I going to give to
anything in creation except then she
goes on and except to the creator of the
heavens and earth an Aramaic the
language Jesus spoke Aloha
so you would say in during Jesus's time
let a light Allah there's nothing worthy
of worship
there's no deity worthy of worship
except the Creator that happens in Earth
except Allah Allah ha hello and ISA
Jesus and it's interesting I heard that
in Ireland they called Jesus because the
English language did not exist his name
wasn't Jesus he spoke Aramaic a Semitic
language and in Ireland they also call I
heard Issa so you would say Issa Rasool
Allah or Jesus is the Messenger of God
not a God literal son of God but a
Messenger of God this is that testimony
of faith makes sense now let's take it
back to Moses this time same thing you
would say like what she was what what
Sinead O'Connor just said la ilaha
il-allah the negation then the
affirmation there's nothing worthy of
worship not the money in my pocket not
the ride not the Bentley not the ship
not the plane because nowadays these
material things have become semi
demigods people are worshiping the
creation or take it a next step above
that people end up worshiping human
beings then they're worshiping their
ideas their desires she said I'm not
gonna do any of that no I've done that
my whole life I'm not gonna do that
except I'm gonna worship the one who
created me the one who made me that
doesn't that make sense if you got your
scruples on right your heart is in place
you're not gonna argue this it makes
sense it makes sense it's logical she
didn't do nothing weird she didn't do
something that now deserves for the
whole world to turn against her when you
don't understand this it becomes like
the other but now we're doing this so
you can come
necked it to something that you might
want to do right now repeat after me
very simple la ilaha illa-llah ash hadu
an la ilaha illallah wa ashhadu anna
muhammadan abduhu wa rasuluh so she
negated all deities nothing worthy of
worship no object except the creator of
the heavens in the earth
the one who doesn't rest the one who
doesn't sleep the one who doesn't become
born or have children he's not like us
human beings
no he's the most perfect in his name's
and attributes he's the most loving the
most kind the most just he created me he
created you I'm just gonna worship
that's the one creator the one God
Almighty in Arabic Allah Aramaic the
language Jesus spoke ilaha and then he
sent a messenger the final messenger
then she made the last of the Shahada
the testimony that Muhammad is the
messenger the servant there was a line
of messengers we went back and we
covered two of them Jesus being one you
would have made that Shahada at his time
and then Moses is time you would have
said la la la la Musa Musa Moses
rasoolallah Moses the Messenger of God
so they were the the way the truth and
the light meaning that you had to follow
them they were the teachers teaching the
message how to get to paradise how to
get to eternal life and salvation they
never taught that someone came and died
for your sins no they taught that god is
the most-loving just and merciful that
you're gonna make mistakes you're gonna
get overcome sometimes you're gonna fall
to temptation but the best of those who
make sins are the ones who turn back to
their creator and worship Him alone and
then try to grow from those mistakes
every mistake is an opportunity to get
better not in making the sin but getting
away from displeasing your Creator
becoming a better human being makes
sense yeah okay
that's why we're doing it so you can go
ahead and investigate this a little bit
further
so during Moses at this time you had to
follow him you have to follow his way
you have to submit to who's he
submitting to he didn't call people to
submit to himself to worship
him no he called people to worship the
one god the creator same thing just go
back to Noah to Abraham same thing we
don't we don't have to go ahead any
further you understand that that's the
Shahada so now you connected back to the
final messenger now and automatically
when you make this Shahada I often
repeat you automatically include you
don't exclude all the preceding
messengers that came before Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon
them all Jesus Moses Abraham just to
name a few these are the greats Abraham
they all call people to worship the
Creator not the creation the one God the
one God Almighty in Arabic Allah now
today the final messenger as she
declared is Muhammad peace and blessings
be upon him and that's it this is what
brings someone into the fold of Islam
submission to the will of the Creator
not the Krait that's what Islam means
and we often we heard her saying
alhamdulillah now you can compare this
for instance and we'll we'll cut out to
one point when we look at the Bible and
what we have left of it attributed to
Jesus because we know that over time has
been changed these are what Bible
scholars telling us not to do all too
much into this but when you look at for
instance what we have left of it which
the Quran confirms the pure monotheism
which is in many places in there for
instance you see this al hamdulillah
being stated in mark 10:18 when one when
a person approached Jesus who by the way
Sinead O'Connor she loves him probably
even more now because that's another
part of this testimony as she did to
acknowledge the messengers so you cannot
deny Jesus you have to believe in him as
he was calling people to believe in him
as a messenger not a God semi-god a
literal son of God but for instance
bringing it back to the alhamdulillah
that she said she was saying for our
Christian friends out there in mark
10:18 there was a man who came to Jesus
what good thing can I do that I might
have eternal life meaning paradise how
do I get to paradise so jesus replied
eSAB replied he said why are you calling
me good there is none good but the one
god you see the the separation how he
separated himself from being one in
purpose with God but not one literally
with God a part of God another God next
to God no he was calling people to pure
monotheism to worship only the one God
and he was saying alhamdulillah that's
like if someone comes up to to our
brother who says this often Habib God
give me everything oh you're a great
fighter you'll see him turn that back to
Allah he'll say alhamdulillah because
I'll strengthen all power is given to
the human being by the crater you can do
any of these things that you do
throughout the day throughout your life
without the blessings of God so you turn
that gratefulness that thankfulness back
to your Creator and the greatest form of
gratitude is what she just did Sinead
O'Connor what she did she took that free
will that she had and she could have
continued on submitting to desires to
money to fame she said no no I'm not
gonna do that I've done that I've
experienced all that and now that's what
leads a person to to despair into
depression and it just from from one
thing to another that never fills the
heart with that solace and contentment
that the human being that peace that
human beings looking for you'll never
find it in these worldly things and the
man-made religions but when she turned
that over and she was sincere and
genuine and she looked for the truth she
asked the Creator the reality who
created all this to guide her and us
that's some homework that I like to
leave people with if you want to do what
she did you're having trouble
trepidations in the heart that void it's
empty it's crying turn to your Creator
sincerely in genuine asks for guidance
ask your Creator why am I here what's
the purpose of life
and then when she found that that's the
greatest thing that a person can do is
to testify to it and then start living
it because talk is cheap you can say you
love God you can say you believe in God
but if you're doing opposite to
everything he made you to do he made you
for in life you're doing opposite of
everything that he wants you to do then
do you really love God or these are just
lip service
imagine you're your mom your whole life
she's asking you to to fulfill some of
her wishes and you keep putting it off
you keep blowing her off you kiss her
but you don't do any of the things and
for years she's asking you do you really
love her no you're selfish you're
selfish and a human being can be very
ungrateful and have a lot of ingratitude
so this is the greatest gratitude when
you take this free will you and now you
you give it back you submit your will to
the will of the one who created you
that's the Shahada that's what she did
and I hope this breakdown of it this
commentary helps you to understand a
little bit better it's very simple it's
logical it's the same way of life the
same thing that was delivered throughout
time because God out of his love he sent
these messengers and all these
messengers came with the same message
calling the human being to worship none
other than the one who created you the
one who made you and to submit your will
to God's will and do your best you're
gonna fall short many of times but God
is the most loving and the most merciful
turn to him with a sincere heart ask for
forgiveness and God will forgive you and
then try your best to keep growing and
becoming better each and every day
because where the focus goes the energy
flows so let your focus be on your
Creator and let that positive energy
come behind it and you will live a
successful life not only in this life
but in the next because we're all gonna
die and that is what should rattle
something inside of you to run towards
what she did what she did well she ran
towards submission to God Islam and that
is what will help you to be
successful in this life to find that
peace and contentment and happiness in
this life but definitely when you die
now
paradise Jena in the next thank you guys
for being with me on this breakdown in
the shaked O'Connor and again a
congratulations to our sisters Sinead
O'Connor on accepting Islam thank you
guys for tuning in subscribe if you
haven't already to the Deen show to get
our show sent to you every week hit the
notification bell peace be with you
Salaam alaikum